one thing Americans definitely not a lot
Canada is Kraft Dinner Kraft Dinner is
Canada's version of Kraft macaroni and
cheese except it's like way more popular
in Canada it's almost the National meal
of Canada so I was talking to Tanya
who's a reporter in the New York office
hey what's up she's Canadian
and she was saying that Kraft Dinner in
Canada is way better than Kraft macaroni
and cheese in America Kraft Dinner
aka Katy is the og name for what
Americans now call mac and cheese so
yeah Canadians I've always kept it real
wait is that true I don't know if that's
true the Americans don't care like a
token Americans about Kraft Dinner and
they gave no shits Justin so confident
that Katie will Trump I'm very confident
well I'm American so I'm just naturally
confident this is all we have this is
all we have I'm holding on to it what
we're gonna do today is a blind taste
test Kraft Dinner from Canada Kraft
macaroni and cheese from America and
we're gonna see which one's actually
better they both look completely
delicious and smell exactly the same
cheesiness looks good not overwhelming
with cheesy looks like creamier and the
noodles are totally different shapes
yeah cheese and pasta still good
actually feel vitamins leaving my body
it's like what you want all food to
taste like but it actually tastes like
it this one has to be American it tastes
like when I was in when I was a kid
growing up oh yeah it's just so much
more substantial than the other one
still awesome I'd say it's less cheesy
ma'am I love to eat this whole thing
this is like option one is like the mac
and cheese you dated in high school
there's the mac and cheese you dated in
college you know I'm saying maybe I
think there's a chance that I'm being
tricked because you know it's such an
American move to have the noodles bigger
than the Canadian ones so I'll have to
go with Canada
hell yeah Kanye I thought this is
Canadian I don't care which one's
Canadian I don't care which one's
American because this is the one I want
to eat option two boom this is a
difficult decision because they were
both totally awesome but I'm gonna say I
like this one better what I'm American
but I like Canadian mac and cheese
mm-hmm
yeah all right so now I know I have to
illegal the import on my mac and cheese
from Canada all right on yeah I have
some interesting news we did come to the
conclusion that the two macaroni and
cheeses American Kraft macaroni and
cheese and Canadian Kraft Dinner do
taste different but in our blind taste
test when people were picking which one
they like better I think something like
four out of six shows the America what I
do things weird that Americans like the
American one better
wait so there were only Americans who
tasted this yeah I mean it's only
Americans in our office that's the huge
bias okay well here's what I think we
should do you there's a few other
Canadians in the New York office do you
want to do a quick taste test of your
own yeah let's do it
I'm nervous I don't know I don't wanna
betray Canada here
it's very rich it's comforting familiar
my heart is telling me to go with this
one
alright well that's because that liked
it more I like this one more so I still
Canada has a better product I'm sorry
for calling you guys did your taste test
did Canadians have a different result
than Americans it was a resounding four
out of four for Canadian Katy which is
crazy right
ultimately we learned that Americans
like American mac and cheese and
Canadians like Canadian Kraft Dinner
they remind us of a home and their
comfort foods so we're gonna pick the
flavors that you know hit closest to
home yeah it also makes me think you
know American Canada we're not so
different but we're just a little
different and they're both they're both
you know tasty just one is a little more
tastier than the other all right well
thank you Tania this has been a very
fascinating journey